what can Indian cinema teach Hollywood I
think the other word teaches frightening
because it's most teachings are
disproved after some time you know
you're teaching wrong and experience
tells you that what you've been taught
is wrong so I think if you can only
exchange experiences and especially
you're talking about an industry I'm not
an individual what Hollywood can
probably pick up there's a lot that
India can pick up from Hollywood
but what Hollywood could possibly pick
up from India is the total tenacity of
purpose to finish a form as a unit
it's not about unions it's not about
people it's not about the liars
it's not about payments it's not about
dotted lines that's good that can happen
but the whole thing is about the content
and the fashion of a group of people
getting together to get this movie done
even for big folks that's not wish a
loop was made and it's it's not about
dotted lines
it's not about liars it's not about ugly
finances oh they did exist it's not that
they were but it's the core group work
together and they we're professionals
but they were amateurs when it came to
managing their love for the phone
they just cave and that rarely happens
that happens in underground film or a
group of young full America starting up
but never in established world unless
it's just happening in Hollywood where
big actors lend their time to make a
film of their choice but it's all the
time like that except members a
commercial film star wakes up from his
nap comes in sort of what's cold cloth
and his Iowa accept gets does his roll
goes back to sleep or read or
have a good time that also happens but
most of the films done in India had done
with a lot of love because they wanted
fischeri is one of them
you